what's amazing is
I could tell why you're such a great
actress
because when I mentioned your father you
immediately tapped into that emotion
just came over you yeah it was like boom
right there yeah you can easily cry on
stage on second year I can but you know
not if it's crap writing right so like
right so like True Blood I
I love scarsgard you know I love him
wow emotional again I know so Alex would
say she'll even cry if she talks about
crying
I cry a lot when it's like I I don't
have any filters at all and but you know
when I was doing a billion guest stars
on every procedural
and it's like
my daughter's mother's brother was at
the brothers dot baby who got killed you
know it's like I don't know how you do
that for 12 hours a day I did it but it
was just
ARG but when it's great writing you know
like so when I got to the seasons where
we found Pam's more vulnerable side
I I would just look at Alex and think if
I don't if I didn't even see him for a
month I could cry about that
so yeah you had a close relationship
with him I did
and so just hearing his name
yeah immediately yeah but I also cried
when I met your dog you got a little
emotional when you hit Blanche you love
dogs I could see it you rescue I love
when people rescue go to arm animal
rescue mission my friend Shiro runs it
Rescue an animal there's so many animals
rescue rescue rescue for God's sake it's
not a purse you don't need a designer
dog what's wrong with people I don't get
it I don't get it you you know you don't
love the thing because it's purebred you
know then that makes you crazy